who's the fastest man alive Sonic
Superman flash now it can't be keemstar
he's the fastest I need to be faster how
can he be so fast there must be an
answer damn it
who is the quickest who is behind this
equation who is the quickest one 2,000
miles per hour
Sonic 2500 miles per hour Superman flash
at 3000 miles per hour all the
calculations are correct
DJ killer accused he's fastest fuck-boy
how can I be so fast with these legs
they're not nearly fast enough okay I'm
the best [ __ ] alive investing keemstar
impossible no one can be faster than
killer keen I'll prove to you that me
and my friends can make it happen
working together using the powers French
and wheels we are strong okay okay
scooter sama I'll go with you
[Applause]
[Music]
we test number one
scooter semaa it's the only way I can go
fast enough if I don't make it back
alive make sure you your sub to keemstar
[Music]
you're one fast but my friends is faster
yeah why don't you introduce me you
haven't seen these rollerblades without
the shoes I got shoots though it's fine
[Music]
who knows killing it
I went real fast but not nearly fast
enough
[Music]
not fast enough
this is the one this is the one that's
gonna take me back to the future
[Music]
I've returned but wait there is more
from the time-space continuum
thank you sponsor space Eagle epic
filmmaking so we're gonna unbox lie
someone steam which is futuristic y'all
ready but wait look great changes theme
every month the 19 make sure that you
order before the 19th to get August
theme anti-hero go to loot crate calm
slash appears entered the code pits you
get 10% up Megaman okay Oh which one am
I gonna get which one do you want my oh
my god Megaman why is he orange that is
that is pretty kawaii so going am i
right
it's actually pretty cool I really like
it it's a good design Michael you want
this I'll take the box I don't know what
this is I just know it's Rick and Morty
but if you know what it is let me know
in the comments or you guys find them
Simpsons because it's my favorite
cartoon and I love the spaceship the
Millennium Falcon oh here we go
hey we did we just started doing this
studio so we have a shelf that we need a
bunch of stuff in a loot crate is
perfect for that okay this is weird this
is the first time I actually don't know
what it is I I mean it says USS
Enterprise so I know it's Star Wars but
Star Fleet
I don't know I don't know why I like
it's this thing that's let me know in
the comments if you know what Star Wars
this is from hey there's also a comic
book it's 4001 a D or dude this is sick
and finally as well
peace be with you from was that is from
Battlestar Galactica okay so we have our
shelf it's that really
I like this little figurines check out
loot crate you get 10% off if used to
link into description loot crate calm
slash pewds and their Dakota pills and
it supports the show and I really
appreciate it it really means a lot and
we get you get you got a good offer on
cool [ __ ] like this
that was fast but it was only 88 miles
per hour and I got a go at least fastest
[ __ ] oh that was my only shot tell me
I'll do anything brand name [ __ ] that
sounds awesome
where is it
[Music]
do you have any idea how fast I am
I'm fastest buck boy
[Music]